-The closing ceremonies of the
Tokyo Olympics was Sunday night,
marking the end of the most
unique Olympics ever.
Two of my writers,
Amber Ruffin and Jenny Hagel,
traveled to Tokyo
for the Olympics,
and they're here with a recap.
Please welcome Jenny and Amber.
-Hi! Yay! Hi, Seth!
-Hey, Seth!
-Welcome back, guys.
So, what are the takeaways
from Tokyo?
-Seth, everybody
is talking about how the U.S.
won the medal count.
-But what no one is talking
about is the U.S.
women's medal count.
-Yeah.
U.S. men won 41 medals --
not bad.
-But the U.S. women
won 66 medals.
-The U.S. women alone won more
medals than Great Britain.
-That's the most embarrassing
thing to happen to England
since the Oprah interview.
[ Laughter ]
-If American women broke off
and became their own country,
they'd be fourth
in the medal count.
-Plus, I bet that country would
have subsidized healthcare.
[ Laughter ]
-This is Molly Seidel.
She won the bronze medal
in the women's marathon.
-It was only the third marathon
she had ever run in her life.
You know when the first one was?
At the Olympic trials.
-This woman was a barista
at a coffee shop,
and she was like, "I think
I'll go to the Olympic trials,"
and she did,
and then she medaled.
-If I was a barista,
I wouldn't even be able
to medal
in getting your order right.
-This is Ashleigh Johnson.
She helped the U.S. women's
water polo team win gold
by blocking 11 shots on goal
in one match.
-She successfully blocked
11 goals.
-I haven't successfully blocked
11 spam calls.
-And this is Allyson Felix.
Last week, she became the most
decorated Olympic track athlete
in American history.
-And she did it while setting up
a fund to provide childcare
for female Olympians with kids.
-This woman went to the
Olympics, took care of business,
and then also took care of like
10 other people's kids.
-Also, Allyson Felix
won two Olympic medals
after she had a baby.
After I had a baby,
all I could do was this.
[ Laughter ]
-The ladies
of Team USA crushed it.
These women won medals.
-These women won medals.
-This woman won like 300 medals.
-Even the women
who didn't medal kicked ass.
Amber and I went to the women's
skateboarding finals,
where the winners were 13,
13, and 16 years old.
-But you know
who came in fourth?
A 34-year-old American woman!
That woman was only
eight years younger
than the other three girls'
ages combined.
-A 34-year-old woman went to
the Olympics and did this.
♪♪
-I can't do that, and I'm 34.
-You're 34?
-Yes.
And I have been
for several years.
-Look, the point we're trying to
make is that Team USA did great!
But they did so in large part
because of the hard work
and talent of American women.
-And also probably
because we were there.
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
Can you give us
some more highlights?
-Sorry, we can't.
We have bobsled practice.
-What?
-Beijing is in like five months.
And the way things
are going for American women,
we figure
we can at least get bronze.
-Amber and Jenny, everyone.